what's the biggest change in terms of
the culture seals the CIA totally
different The Hazing that kind of stuff
there's a 100 no-go there's no hazing
there's no tuning people up you're
working with women you're working with
Nerds you're working with a whole slew
of different people in the SEAL Teams
through with 16 guys and everybody's a
meat eater everybody wants to go to war
everybody's hardened Everybody's In
Shape you move over the CIA and an
outfit that I was in under the agency
all those aspects are still there my
immediate team you're dealing with spies
you're dealing with intelligence foreign
intelligence people you're D you gotta
wear a suit Sometimes You Gotta Wear
what you're wearing in the Seal team
sometimes one day you might be meeting
the president of Afghanistan you know
high-end Diplomat from another country
and the next day you're pumping the
mountains in Afghanistan with an M4 the
job is so broad when you get over there
yeah